[Music]
I'm a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga coming to you from the heart of
Berlin and after months of uncertainty
Angela Merkel has finally managed to
form a new coalition government she'll
be sworn in for a fourth term as German
Chancellor next week and she'll once
again be at the head of a grand
coalition government made up of the two
biggest parties the Chancellor's own
Conservatives and the Social Democrats
now people are though asking how wounded
is Angela Merkel after recent setbacks
and is she a waning force domestically
and internationally so our question here
this week on quadriga is merkel 4.0
still the power throw and even if her
power is perhaps a little bit on the
decline we are talking today about the
most influential female politician in
the world and that on March the 8th
International Women's Day and I'm joined
here in the studio by three female
commentators let me introduce them to
you beginning with my soon Mellon who is
with DW she's on our Arab language desk
Syrian born my soon says while her
Social Democrat coalition partners
struggle to revive their fortunes the
Chancellor can work calmly on her legacy
Angela Merkel is far from wounded also
with this is DW Polk political
correspondent Nina Haase and Lena argues
that Angela Merkel must take the hand
that Emmanuel macron has stretched out
they only have a narrow window of
opportunity to keep the EU together
serious stuff and Pascal is also with us
she's an author and journalist for the
French magazine Lacroix and she says a
disastrous result in September's
election followed by months of
quarreling and deadlock it is a weakened
Angela Merkel that will be sworn in next
Wednesday plenty of interesting stuff
I'd like to begin with you Nina you'd be
following events very closely in the
recent weeks and months
lots of quarreling lots of haggling
finally we have a new government what
should we expect from this new coalition
from the outside it may look like we're
going to get more of the same because we
of course have to remember that the past
eight
of 12 years and we've the German people
have been governed by a so-called grand
coalition and of course there is
frustration here in Germany that people
are getting the feeling that whatever
they vote for they always end up with a
grand coalition and Merkel and with
Uncle Michael at the helm of it and of
course I think that from the outside of
course it looks like more of the same
but it isn't Angela Merkel is under
tremendous pressure here at home and I'm
I'm sure that we're going to talk about
what exactly that is but it is new and
different okay my second I know it's not
the kind of question I ought to ask but
are you a fan of Angela Merkel well I'm
not and I think mainly because I don't
have the quality of being a fan of a
political figure sure I do appreciate
her I do appreciate many things she did
in the last two years and back in 2008
and in many parts of her bit of her
being a Chancellor I like her being
patient and smart and I like her wake of
governance but I don't consider myself a
person okay so you like the Merkel style
is she still the dominant force in
German politics it's that only doubt
about that at all well she's a powerful
person I think she's still one of the
most powerful persons maybe the most
powerful person in Germany but I don't
like the word dominant force to describe
her because dominance is not really the
best way to describe her way of
governing angular Merkel had always the
strategy of listening carefully to what
the public mood wants to hear and say
and present what the public mood wants
as her own choice and her decision so
it's not dominance it's actually the
opposite of being dominant mm-hmm Pascal
oogh at the top of the show in your
statement you said that angular Merkel
is after all the quarreling that we've
already mentioned all the uncertainty
that has gone before is weakened tell us
more well you know she's she hasn't won
the election grandiosely she's she's
scored the election was not very good
then she went through months and months
of quarreling and delay
and to form this coalition and you look
at her
it shows she looks he looks very strange
she looked a bit older she looks very
tired so on the other hand I'm gonna
marry somebody who's always in for
surprises she is very very able to
rebounce and there is at the moment
nobody else who could take her part and
she is very much liked in broad she's
very much like Emmanuelle McCall the
French president was completely relieved
when the grand coalition was formed that
he could work with Merkel again and not
have in Germany some kind of politician
who where was not European so you have
to remember it's a bit like Gorbachev
she's more like outside Germany than she
is in Germany you know you well yeah I
would I would argue also that you could
you could clearly see that since
September's elections and the political
parties here in Germany didn't really
want to go together with Merkel they all
know that they're going to lose their
profile if they're in a government with
Angela Merkel the SPD was was punished
for that they lost tremendously they
lost seven percent percentage points in
the elections and Christiane Lindner the
head of the business-friendly FDP who
Angela Merkel had favoured as a
candidate to govern with he pulled out
of the coalition negotiations because I
think he could also see that the FDP
were going to lose their own profile
their own identities America like my son
says it's she's extremely good at just
assessing a situation looking at what's
on the table and making it her own
eventually and just to pick up on this
point that Pascal made our macro know
Merkel the two M's now going to sort of
come together as a tandem and put things
right for Europe I mean you indicated in
your statements at the top of the show
that your office is in peril they have
to I think here in Germany sometimes
we're walking on on a bit of a cloud you
know ignoring what's going on around
Germany and it's Angela Merkel's refugee
policy has created a lot of opposition
outside of Germany and we're still busy
trying to find out who's going to be are
we going to have a state minister or a
Minister for digital affairs so you know
Angela Merkel
has to exactly accept a manual in
Michaels hand because next year we're
going to see European elections and
we're already experiencing a rise in
popular ISM and things are going to get
a lot harder of the right-wing populists
win even more votes talk about the
problem my son you wanted to come in I
think there's another big reason or
important reason why she would like to
work with McCall the last six months she
was exhausted and very busy with her
efforts to forge a government or
coalition with any partner and that was
the time where McCune managed to present
himself at the man of Europe as a new
power in Europe
she lost a bit of her profile like
flower oppa or foul Europe and I think
she would like to work with him now to
regain some of the things she lost in
the last six months and I think she will
manage to do a lot of people I mean
we're talking about Merkel Hill were
talking about Merkel the survivor where
one people have said that she doesn't
have necessarily a big idea she doesn't
have a vision is that fair criticism
does she have a vision Pascal well she's
a pragmatic politician and I think
Germans don't like visionary politicians
you know everybody's calling here for
vision and and everybody's worshipping
this young president we have now who has
a vision and who has ideas and and the
Germans would like somebody like that
but when it comes to voting they want
stability and I think Germany's is a
much Merkel is a typical German
politician you know she's not very
different in her art from Helmut Kohl
they like this sort of solid don't rock
the boat too much so she fits Germany
but the two of them you know you have a
young French president and a man and
chimerical who has also her qualities of
being very pragmatic and very kind and
maybe the two of them will be able we
hope to pull Europe forward well I would
also say that she's a scientist and that
shows in the way you know I often find
it surprising that we have to look at I
mean she wrote a dissertation about the
decay of structures and which factors
are accelerating decay
so you know she knows how systems work
and so what she does in politics as in
science is she looks at the variables on
the table and she'll calculate and if
she finds that there's a new variable
that she has to take into account she
will do I don't call that vision
I call that calculating but it is you
know in her way it is predictable how
sad that her having an over dream I
think it doesn't have much do with
Germans but with the period was the
period you are living in we are living
in a time of crisis I mean Germany had
someone with vision that was Schroeder
he was a very extraordinary Chancellor
we had him for four years and that was
enough now we are living in a time of
crisis where we need more stability more
scientists someone who was able talking
with Schroeder you're talking about his
radical reform of the labor market here
in Germany yeah there really
kick-started the German economy
something like this for example just to
fill in for our viewers I said we're
talking about angle America warm word
that I would like to use about Angela
Merkel is that she sometimes appears to
be a little bit unknowable she's even
nicknamed sometimes the Sphinx and one
thing that people often ask is relevant
to today's discussion here on quadriga
is she a feminist Angela Merkel likes to
surround herself with women she can
trust
for example she brought Anna great camp
Kevin Bauer the state premier of Holland
to Berlin and made her the CDU
secretary-general it's an important post
still feminism doesn't seem to play a
big role in the Chancellor's universe do
you consider yourself a feminist
even so more women are now joining
methods covenant three out of six CDU
ministers will now be women one is
already a known quantity
defense minister whose laFonda lion
continues in her old role and the sexes
are also evenly divided among Social
Democrats for the first time in its
150-year history the party could soon be
led by a woman andrean Alice the Labour
Minister in the last grand coalition
women in positions of political power in
Germany now a commonplace idea yeah good
question Pascale let's talk about the
cabinet before we talk about the
Bundestag everybody's saying the cabinet
is gonna be more or less 50/50 men and
women and it a lot of people are acting
as though that's a really big deal it's
not really though is it I mean why what
is it well it's the most normal thing in
the world and it shows yeah it's sad
that it's a big deal and that the
headlines of all the German papers was
about that and showing these ladies in
in you know in bright colours on the
front paper yeah it's a it's it's it's
normal and it's high time okay so that
may be normal at the same time however
I've got some figures Nina you will have
noted that of the seven hundred and nine
members of the Bundestag four hundred
and ninety nearly five hundred are men
just 219 of women just under thirty one
percent the lowest level since 2002 what
the heck is going on I think the most
shocking thing was that the percentage
of women actually slumped drops by six
percent I mean it's it's a significant
drop in numbers and of course one of the
reasons is that of the AFD the far-right
party entered the alternative for
Germany and that party became the
strongest party with men in East Germany
we mustn't forget that as well you know
they they were stronger than any of the
other parties and there is a party in
the Bundestag which is the FDP
important they're all male yeah I think
the least percentage of women even the
members of the party so no
there's such a few women part in the
book that's asked me the AFD but you
know they are very very close even at
the number the numbers of the members of
the party the VFD the 92 members of
parliament just ten women that's not
happened by their most prominent party
yeah she wasn't that she was an
established figure almost on the
international stage she's gone okay but
what what's happening in the alternative
for Germany why is it happening that
there are so few women I think there is
a strong feeling with some people that
there's too much chaos and especially
the AFD wants clearer roles for men and
women there they're very open about you
know they're anti-abortion stance some
members of the party and yeah probably
they're just not happy with the with a
feminist left-wing liberal times were
living in okay you've said feminists we
had other little piece that we just
watch we were all amused but it's an
important moment I think Angela Merkel
Pascal was asked is she a feminist and
she she hummed and she hard yet is
Angela Merkel a feminist it's a
difficult thing with a feminist because
it's become a very dubious word if you
ask me I wouldn't say I'm a FEMINIST
it's a it's a you know you have it's
it's it's a complicated world but no I
don't think she what she is in what she
embodies because she's you know the
queen of Europe the most powerful woman
in the world and and because maybe
because also her style is maybe feminine
not so aggressive not so I mean compared
to get out further the SPD counselor
who's a match or where she listens to
people that's maybe a feminine style but
she hasn't done very much for the cause
of women in her country I mean she's
been very drawn back they go along with
this myself I think she she did she did
it very clearly and she's been through
the 12 years she is being a chancellor
she's been playing down her gender just
to avoid any label of feminism that
she's making it seem as though it's the
most normal thing in the world for the
Chancellor of Germany to be a woman yes
perspective she's not an iron woman
she's the Moochie the mother here so
she's not she's really playing down her
gender she wants she doesn't want to be
in any rival situation when out with
other men so I don't think she's a
feminist okay we're talking about Angela
Merkel she is not one for great juicy
soundbite so let's listen to what she
had to say after last Sunday's vote
confirmed that she did indeed have a new
coalition government it's 50 saying it
will be important to get to work quickly
in the new government and as the
possible Chancellor I hope I will be
elected I can and will throw all of my
energy into this government so that it
will work well for the people in Germany
thank you typical Merkel sternly in a
dry pragmatic you know cautious I think
it is impressive how she has managed to
remain a mystery even to most political
correspondents you know we still don't
really know her we she is very
predictable when it comes to where she
spends her holidays and how to use that
organizes her life but she's a mystery
she will pull tricks out of her hat in a
surprising fashion like how she managed
to appoint an elite come Karen Bauer
nobody had expected that and you could
tell that Angela Merkel was really
really pleased her effectively successor
and yeah that is just something that
will always remain a mystery to me how
she has this power instinct more than
other people was interesting what Pascal
was saying Pascal was saying that the
Germans want somebody they want a leader
who is pragmatic they want an
unspectacular leader I come a consensual
leader yeah but my impression in the
last couple of weeks there have been so
many people have been saying they would
like to see German politics more
polarized they would like to see more to
use the German word straight they want
more conflict and controversy would that
be better for Germany I think uncle
America if we're talking about her
works according to the motto keep your
friends close and your enemies closer so
you know she she manages to whenever
there is the bubbling whenever a public
Rao within her own party is about to
break out she manages to contain it very
quickly she did so with yen span
appointing one of her most vocal critic
as the new health minister is one such
macklemore you know she will make sure
that they have to adhere to a cabinet
discipline and I'm not sure whether
we're going to see much more arguments
on the public stage and I don't know
when you mentioned Yun span he really is
the angry young man of the not quite so
young relatively a young man if the
Conservatives I mean is there are there
two different styles and a banal
question but an important one a men more
aggressive than women in politics is
there is there a difference between the
way women do politics in the way men do
politics it's like men it's a very
difficult question you have aggressive
politicians like and like Margaret
Thatcher I mean whose really hard and
and and you have soft men who govern
their countries different dates it's I
can't answer this question it's very
difficult at the SPD compare martin
chose two or three analyst and you can
say who's more aggressive than the other
a woman and a man I mean it doesn't have
to do with gender as itself as itself
rather it has to do with the the way you
live your gender and you play your
gender you present yourself hmm I'm
wondering though I mean if it's an
interesting theoretical question at
least is if there were 60% women in the
Bundestag in the German parliament would
it be different and would it be better
well I what we have now I would say it
would still not represent society you
know because 60% women we don't live in
a 60% women's society I think it's very
important that the Bundestag represents
society as best as it can and at the
moment it's not doing that it's very
male also it's very academic
I would argue that and very wise exactly
so I would argue that what the German
voters have for the last couple of
months and years felt is that somehow
politicians are becoming more distanced
and they're talking within themselves
within their own bubbles and that is an
extremely dangerous when women come into
politics they became men who was it
Margaret Thatcher she's the only man in
cabinet you know they act like make me
dress like men they lose their charm
they lose their wits they lose I mean
things which can be can be said are
women attributes and and and if we mean
if we had 50% women in in government and
in the political instances who were
acting like women then it might change
something and there are vertical
difference Michael did but there are
very few few women for young girls to
look up to in politics but also in
businesses you know people who talk
about their family life and who look
like happy people family people you need
these kind of people you need these kind
of role models but if you never see
politicians with their families you get
an idea that okay I have to choose as a
young person if I want to be active in
politics that probably means I can't
have a happy family life and as a woman
you have to hide the family exactly
Gabrielle the yetze I was foreign
minister you know he you know you he
shows himself with his daughter he says
oh that's nice I'm not guy can spend a
lot of time with my daughter it's
impossible for a woman you just hide the
fact that you have to so that's that's a
huge psychological properties thing but
nevertheless let's not forget that
Germany had a different face in the 70s
that was a time when the woman still had
to get an acceptance from her husband to
go to work in 40 years and if you look
at the pro-life movement that's gaining
momentum across the world there are
dangerous and developments happening
around the world that we might see
developments and turned back quite soon
in some country was interesting what you
said about young girls be look seeing
Angela Merkel as possibly a role model I
actually I
I asked my daughter yesterday evening
when I was preparing for the show I
suddenly had her on the phone I said
what do you think I said spontaneously
what do you think of Angela Merkel and
she said that she surprised me she said
Angela Merkel is cool my daughter's not
inclined to vote for angular Merkel by
the way but she said she's cool because
she's a pioneer that was the word to you
she has empowered women by showing that
it can be done as a woman yeah one
question though is that you know we've
talked about how women are
underrepresented in gia in business and
commerce here in Germany we've talked
about how women are underrepresented in
in Parliament yeah the glass ceiling
still seems to be relatively thick here
in Germany I don't understand why there
are so many inspiring women in Germany
and why so few of them get to the top I
need an explanation for each of you I
think it's about legislations we still
need some more lows which enable women
to live home and her children in safety
maybe her husband caring about the
children when she goes to work and to to
do something in her work and it's also
about a German a very German phrase
which I like Titus life not there not
there I have to say it in a world isn't
ready for it yet to happen I'm positive
that will happen in a future I think
it's psychology and tradition you don't
have that in France this when you get a
child here you have to choose or you say
you know you don't put a child in the
world to give in to a kindergarten you
have to it's not the case in England
that's not the case in France and
there's a it's a very much vehicle
Society and and and I don't know any
world I mean it's always complicated
with guilt when you have children you
know do you leave them too long alone
are you a good mother and but in Germany
it's exceptionally this guilt is very
very strong and so I can imagine that
for a lot of women it's difficult to
have positions in the in the economy or
in politics where you're very often away
from home there's not much structures -
I mean kindergarten cribs to give you
children I think it's a it's a it's a
historical it's a tradition and it's a
it's a very big guilt trip in this
country I would say two things that a we
need more men talking about gender
equality and not just women talking
about we're promoting women's rights and
like the he for she campaigned by the
United Nations for example I think
that's a tremendously important a little
bit more about that well it's basically
trying to find male people male role
models promoting gender equality and
speaking out in favor of giving young
girls a chance etc and you know famous
people and then the other thing is that
once women when women entered structures
in the parties in the political parties
but also in businesses etc they already
found the structures in place that had
been set up by men and it takes a very
long time to change my son and all the
things we've been talk of originally
from Syria and you were born in Syria I
mentioned at the beginning that I'm just
curious to see to hear whether there is
a specific perspective from the Arab
world from Syria that on these issues
that we talked about today it's similar
to here but amplified you need more
legislation more lows to empower women
in the Arab world and I think society
changed by Loes okay I can hear the
music the clock is ticking with the time
is nearly over I'd just like to ask you
Angela Merkel still the power throw I
think she still is I mean a point again
span and unequipped come combo
Wow it was audacious wasn't it angular
Merkel's sister but not dominant let's
go find the works I think still and soon
she'll be the powerful in Europe again
with the French president okay much look
forward so thank you very very much for
joining us here today on quad Riga if
you've enjoyed the show come back next
week we've been talking about Angela
Merkel 4.0 still the power for help
thanks very much for joining us bye-bye
just
[Music]